>> Laura: THAT IS AWESOME,
5500 TESTS DONE, DR. STEPHEN
SMITH, YOU ARE THE BEST,
THANK YOU.
WE TOLD YOU OVER THE LAST MANY
MONTHS ABOUT SOME OF THE HIDDEN
COST OF COVID COME WITH THE
SPIKE IN SUICIDE, DRUG OVERDOSE,
DOMESTIC ABUSE, BUT THERE IS
ANOTHER ONE HIDDEN BENEATH THE
SURFACE, CHILD SEX TRAFFICKING.
NOW TIM BALLARD FOUNDER OF
OPERATION UNDERGROUND RAILROAD
SAID IT HAS RISEN TO A LEVEL HE
HAS NEVER SEEN ALL DUE TO THESE
DRACONIAN LOCKDOWNS AND
INCREASED PROTESTS.
NOW IT INCLUDES ONE OF THE WORST
CRIMINAL GANGS IN THE WORLD.
NEARLY A DOZEN MS-13 GANG
MEMBERS WERE ARRESTED IN
VIRGINIA FOR TRAFFICKING AND
BRUTALLY BEATING A 13-YEAR-OLD
GIRL.
THE MAN PROSECUTED IN THE CASE
ZACHARY TELL RAEL OCCUR FOR THE
EASTERN DISTRICT OF VIRGINIA MAD
CLEAR THE OPERATIONS NEED
LEADERS IN OFFICE WHO WILL NOT
SHY AWAY FROM TARGETING THIS
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY.
>> COMBATING MS-13 IS NOT
ANTI-IMMIGRANT BUT
PRO-IMMIGRANT.
WE ARE GOING AFTER THE PEOPLE
PRAYING ON OUR COMMUNITIES.
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS KEY TO THIS
OPERATION BUT YOU KNOW WHO ELSE
IS KEY TO THIS ELECTED LEADERS
AND CALLING OUT WHAT IS ACTUALLY
GOING ON.
>> Laura: JOINING THE NOW U.S.
ATTORNEY HIMSELF, WHY DID YOU
FIND THAT PARTICULAR MESSAGE SO
IMPORTANT?
>> THANKS A LOT, LAURA.
IT IS KEY IF WE WILL ACTUALLY
ATTACK THIS PROBLEM.
WE HAVE TO IDENTIFY IT AND IT
NEEDS TO BE A GOVERNMENT
APPROACH.
SO MUCH ABOUT MS-13 GETS
POLITICIZED AND FOLKS WILL SAY
IT IS ANTI-IMMIGRANT.
AS WE DISCUSSED AND YOU JUST
SHOWED, IT IS KEY THAT MS-13
PREYS UPON THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY.
THEY SIX TREKKED THEIR DAUGHTERS
AND BRUTALLY ATTACKED THEIR SONS
AND EXTORTS INDIVIDUALS,
HARDWORKING IMMIGRANTS IN THIS
COUNTRY BY THREATENING THE
VIOLENCE HERE IN EL SALVADOR.
FOR SO MANY IF YOU SEEK TO
ENFORCE ANY TYPE OF RULE LAW
AGAINST THIS GAME, IT IS
ANTI-IMMIGRANT AND THAT IS
SIMPLY NOT THE CASE.
>> Laura: NOW, THIS IS HOW
BIDEN HAS BEEN DISCUSSING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION, WATCH.
>> THERE WILL NOT BE ANOTHER
FOOT OF WALL CONSTRUCTED ON MY
ADMINISTRATION.
11 MILLION UNDOCUMENTED ALIENS
ARE ALREADY AMERICANS IN MY
VIEW.
>> Laura: WOULD A BIDEN
PRESIDENCY HURT EFFORTS
COMBATING MS-13 IF THE BORDER IS
GOING TO BE TREATED IN A WAY
THAT IT SEEMS IT WILL BE TREATED
BY BIDEN LIKE AN INCONVENIENCE
AND SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
MONITORED BUT CERTAINLY NOT THE
WAY THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
HAS?
>> FROM WHERE I’M SITTING, LAURA
AND I WILL LEAVE TO OTHERS TO
DETERMINE WHAT A BIDEN
PRESIDENCY WILL LOOK LIKE.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU PROOF
POSITIVE WHEN WE HAVE A GANG
LIKE HIM IS 13 AND WE ATTACK
THEM CLICK BY CLICK AND
DISMANTLE THEM, WHEN WE HAVE A
POROUS BORDER, INDIVIDUALS
FLOODING ACROSS THAT BORDER IN
2019 I THINK THE HIGH WATER MARK
WAS 144,000 ENCOUNTERS IN A
MONTH.
WE ARE DOWN IN APRIL TO 16,000.
WE CAN ACTUALLY GAIN A FOOTHOLD
AND WE CAN GET AHEAD, BUT WHEN
AN INDIVIDUAL WHO WANTS TO COME
HERE AND DO HARM AND JOIN GANGS
LIKE MS-13 RR READY -- ALREADY
GANG MEMBERS FLITTING ACROSS THE
BORDER, IT IS A WHACK A MOLE AND
CAN’T WIN.
THERE ARE CASES IN THE EASTERN
DISTRICT OF VIRGINIA WHERE WE’VE
HAD INDIVIDUALS, GANG MEMBERS
WHO HAVE BEEN DEPORTED AND THEY
ARE BACK IN THE
WASHINGTON, D.C., AREA IN THREE
TO FOUR WEEKS AFTER DEPORTATION.
THAT JUST DOESN’T WORK.
>> Laura: WHAT PEOPLE ALSO
HAVE TO KNOW THAT THIS IS BIG
MONEY.
AND JUST LIKE THE DRUG TRADE IS
BIG MONEY, TRAFFICKING THESE
YOUNG IMMIGRANT GIRLS UP FROM
COUNTRIES IN CENTRAL AMERICA
THAT IS BIG BUSINESS.
>> WHAT WE HAVE FIGURED OUT IS
JUST AWFUL.
DRUGS CAN BE SOLD AND A HUMAN
BEING CAN BE SOLD OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
AND AGAIN LIKE MS-13 AND OTHERS,
ARE EXTREMELY WELL SITUATED TO
RECRUIT THESE YOUNG GIRLS,
INTIMIDATE THEM INTO SILENCE,
BRUTALLY BEAT THEM INTO
SUBMISSION AND RATE THEM AND
TURNED THEM OUT INTO A
POPULATION THAT IS EQUALLY
AFRAID OF MS-13 TO SAY ANYTHING
ABOUT WHAT IS GOING ON IN THEIR
OWN COMMUNITIES.
IT IS A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
MONEY.
IT IS A RESORT THAT THESE GANGS
JUST EXPLOIT OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
AND CARRIES VERY LITTLE RISK
COMPARED TO DRUG TRAFFICKING.
SNOW AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR SERVICES TO THE CONTRARY IN